digamos que eres un cazador y recolector
y estás tratando de encontrar la manera
de repartir tu tiempo tanto para cazar
como para recolectar ok entonces
pensemos algunos escenarios y sus
ventajas también sus desventajas y de
manera simple supongamos que cuando
hablamos de cazar el único animal
disponible son conejos y cuando hablamos
de recolectar el único producto
disponible son algunos tipos de bayas
con eso trabajaremos ahora y pensemos en
algunos escenarios digamos en este caso
el escenario hay digamos que este es el
número de conejos
conejos y llamemos a este otro número el
número de bayas
muy bien ok esto va a ser en esta
columna
entonces si planeas gastar todo el día
buscando conejos todo tu tiempo libre
digamos suponiendo que tienes tiempo de
dormir cambiarte y todas esas cosas
digamos que puedes tener 5 conejos
aproximadamente en el día ok pero si
gastas todo el tiempo consiguiendo
conejos ya no tienes tiempo para las
bayas entonces tendrás 0 bayas
ahora digamos que gastarás un poco más
de tiempo con las bayas un poco y
entonces tendrás un poco menos con los
conejos digamos este es el escenario b
en donde tendrás tiempo para conseguir 4
conejos en promedio y si haces eso
podrás conseguir a lo mejor 100 bayas
conseguiste 100 bayas
vamos a dejarlo así bien y ahora cuando
hacemos los los diferentes escenarios
asumimos que todo lo demás es igual
verdad que no cambias la cantidad de
tiempo en la que casas o recolectas no
cambias la cantidad de tiempo para
dormir las técnicas de cazar de
recolección de bayas no estás utilizando
otro tipo de cosas distintas y el
término general de esto suena muy
rimbombante si estuvieras a lo mejor en
una conversación pero es tetris paribus
ceterista paribus y que literalmente
significa digamos cuando estés con
alguien puede decir ahora ya sabes el
trees paribus asumimos estos cambios
variables quiere decir que estás
asumiendo que todo lo demás se mantiene
igual así que es éter y significa
todas las cosas
todas las cosas las demás cosas digamos
que puedes familiarizarlo con etcétera
verdad con la palabra etcétera la misma
palabra esencialmente y paribus es igual
así que cuando vayas del escenario a al
b no cambiarás la cantidad de sueño la
geografía de alguna de alguna manera
dramáticamente claro no cambiarás las
herramientas la tecnología usada todo lo
demás es igual la única variable que
cambiará será cuánto tiempo le dedicas
para encontrar conejos o bayas así que
veamos más escenarios digamos
asumiendo paribus digamos el escenario
sé que en promedio pueden conseguir tres
conejos pero si tienes tres conejos de
pronto sólo podrás conseguir o
conseguirás digamos 180 bayas ok ahora
podrás conseguir 180 bayas hagamos unas
más digamos dos escenarios más del
escenario de si reduces el tiempo para
conseguir conejos obtendrás solo dos
conejos pero de ahora ahora de repente
tienes suficiente tiempo para conseguir
240 bayas en promedio y digamos en la
situación
ahí vamos a poder cazar un conejo en
promedio pero tenemos más tiempo para
encontrar bayas y digamos que podemos
conseguir 280 vamos a hacer un escenario
más aquí digamos del escenario efe que
estos son los escenarios verdad la
situación es entonces el escenario efe
es gastar todo el tiempo en bayas y
digamos que conseguimos 300 pero como ya
no tenemos tiempo para conseguir conejos
pues no conseguiremos alguno así que lo
que quiero hacer es señalar a partir de
esto un en un eje vamos a graficar esto
en un eje voy a tener la cantidad de
conejos vamos a este eje este es el eje
de los conejos y vamos a empezar desde
cero desde cero
digamos 1 2
tres cuatro y hasta cinco ok y en este
otro eje este haré el eje de las vallas
digamos aquí son las bayas aquí digamos
por aquí son 100 vallas aquí 200 vallas
y hasta acá arriba son 300 vallas
entonces este es el eje de las vallas
muy bien ahora pongamos estos distintos
escenarios primero digamos el escenario
entonces tenemos 5 conejos tal vez
tenemos 5 col conejos y 0 bayas entonces
lo pintamos en él
en este punto justo aquí este es el
escenario a el escenario ves son cuatro
conejos y 100 bayas este digamos va a
estar por acá está por acá muy bien
este es el escenario b
ahora el escenario se son tres conejos y
180 bayas digamos y aquí estamos en tres
conejos por aquí está 150 más o menos
por aquí está el 180 así que para tres
conejos vamos a asociar 180 bayas en
promedio por supuesto y este es el
escenario se en el escenario de
tendremos 22 conejos ok y para dos
conejos tendremos 240 bayas entonces
esto está bien por aquí el escenario de
ok bueno
déjenme pintarlo mejor porque si aquí
está 250 tenemos que estar un poquito
más abajo de eso verdad entonces aquí
está el escenario d
y el escenario y si tienes tiempo para
un conejo tendremos 280 bayas eso nos
lleva más o menos por aquí
exacto este es el escenario y finalmente
el escenario efe gastas todo tu tiempo
en bayas sin tiempo para los conejos
entonces todo tu tiempo se va en las
bayas no hay conejos pero conejos pero
ponemos 300 vallas por aquí y este es el
escenario efe ahora estos son los puntos
y que representan déjenme ponerle una
palabra llamativa pero realmente es una
idea simple todo esto son los puntos que
tú como cazador y recolector son tu
frontera de posibilidades porque si
dibujamos una línea digamos solamente
arbitrariamente elegir estos escenarios
aunque en promedio a lo mejor puedes
tener 4.5 conejos o 3.5 conejos en fin
puedes tener un buen de diferentes
combinaciones entre los conejos y bayas
que puedes colectar digamos déjenme
hacer esta línea en realidad sólo se
debería haber una sola curva verdad
déjenme dibujarlo con una línea punteada
más o menos esta curva de aquí
esta representa la posibilidad de más
bien las posibles combinaciones de
conejos y bayas solo escogí algunas de
ellas pero puedes tener un escenario por
aquí digamos este pueblo le puedes
llamar g que es la cantidad de tiempo en
donde utiliza bueno perdón consigues 4.5
conejos digamos un día 4 y luego 5
conejos así en promedio tienes 4.5 y se
puede ver qué consigue 50 vallas pero
bueno todas estas son posibilidades
verdad no necesariamente tienes que
saltar de 4 a 5 conejos ya sabes puedes
gastar a lo mejor en este escenario
puedes gastar 7 horas y en este otro 8
horas o 7 horas y un minuto no sé todo
esto en medio es posible y todas estas
posibilidades están en la curva estos
cinco escenarios son son deberían en
realidad bueno es decir son seis
escenarios pero son solo algunos son
sólo esos escenarios en esta curva y
esta curva es a la que llamamos de nuevo
bueno con este término llamativo pero
que tiene una idea simple es nuestra
frontera de producción
perdón la frontera de posibilidades de
producción
frontera de posible ok de posibilidades
de producción
porque nos muestra las diferentes
posibilidades que podemos hacer en
contra de conejos contra bayas verdad
digamos los conejos y 240 bayas lo que
si podemos lo que sí no podemos hacer es
algo que esté más allá de esto por
ejemplo no podemos tener un escenario
como éste
este sería imposible
sería déjenme moverme
moverme tantito a la derecha pero este
punto sería imposible
ok donde obtengo cinco conejos y digamos
200 vallas porque si obtengo cinco
conejos estos éstos los obtuve gastando
todo el día y no habría tiempo para las
bayas ok
perfecto entonces este punto sería
imposible
de hecho cualquier punto que esté por
arriba de la curva es imposible ahora
este punto de este lado de la curva
digamos digamos dentro de la curva por
debajo de ella oa la izquierda todos
estos son posibles este punto por
ejemplo déjenme tomar este punto
por ejemplo para mí es muy fácil obtener
un conejo y 200 bayas verdad esto es
posible ahora no es óptimo porque si
trabajara adecuadamente podría obtener
más bayas o más conejos verdad pero si
tengo 200 bayas y si yo quiero solo
puedo conseguir puedo solo conseguir un
conejo verdad todos estos puntos de
abajo son posibles pero no son óptimos
no son eficientes y los puntos de aquí
digamos que no son eficientes
no son eficientes o de alguna manera no
estoy usando mis óptimos recursos verdad
para hacer que esta que esta producción
digamos de aquí es solo que no estoy
enfocado de la forma óptima verdad que
si hablamos de un ajuste de fábrica
podemos hablar acerca de decidir una u
otra estrategia para utilizar de forma
óptima los recursos entonces todos los
puntos de la frontera si son eficientes
haces todo lo que puedes hacer
no estamos haciendo ningún prejuicio
entre que esta o la otra posibilidad son
mejor simplemente estamos diciendo que
estas de que estamos haciendo lo mejor
que se pueda